bertrand delanoë est l'invité de preuves
par 3 monsieur le maire de paris bonsoir
soit merci d'être avec nous vous entrez
en campagne pour françois hollande sans
état d'âme depuis votre clash avec
martine aubry n'est ce pas après le
parachutage des flots j'ai l'habitude de
dire ce que je pense voilà on en parlera
tout à l'heure avec corinne delpech de
l' agence france-presse
dans un quart d'heure la dernière partie
des missions et perrine tarneaud de
public sénat sera consacrée aux dossiers
parfois ou aux polémiques parisiennes et
qui appelle des réponses de votre part
heures on a beaucoup de questions à vous
poser sur votre gestion à paris d'abord
bertrand delanoë vous êtes sans doute
sensible à la démarche d'eric cantona
d'ailleurs vous avez fait du logement
votre priorité pour 2012 est ce que vous
espérez que l'ex star du foot obtienne
ses 500 signatures des mères c'est pas
ma priorité pour 2012 la priorité depuis
que je suis maire de paris d'alors je
sais pas si l'honneur vous avez remarqué
mais à 110000 parisien ben qui se loge
quelque part ça doit être qu'on a mené
une politique de logement en plus voilà
il y en a pas cent dix mille ans tous en
être une dernière chance
deuxièmement je trouve que c'est très
important qu eric cantona met sa
notoriété sa popularité au service de la
cause du logement qu'ils le fassent avec
la fondation abbé pierre
j'entendais tout à l'heure patrick
doutreligne qui est le président de la
fondation abbé pierre et que j'ai nommé
ya trois ans mon examinateurs principal
exigeant et indépendant sur la politique
du logement à paris donc tout ça est
très sain car il faut que l'élection
présidentielle permettent un changement
de la politique du logement dans les
communes au niveau de l'état donc c'est
pas une question de 500 signatures je
pense pas que ma ville et demande lui il
les mérite ce qu'il est fou il fallait
réunir mais moi je vais pas lui de yens
attendus n'avaient pas vous donner
benzema françois hollande mais je suis
heureux que grâce à lui et à la
fondation abbé pierre
le thème du logement devient un thème
majeur de cette campagne présidentielle
après chacun fait comme il veut
avec sa méthode moi ce qui m'importe
c'est le fond et qu'est ce qui va
changer en france par l'élection de
françois hollande pas d'eric cantona sur
la question de logement
c'est vrai que eric cantona de toute
façon on n'est pas candidat mais enfin
il veut ses 500 signatures on verra s'il
les obtient est ce que ça ne serait pas
paradoxal et même dangereux va de lui
accorder ses 500 parrainages
alors que marine le pen qui est
candidate ne les obtiendrait pas non
mais ça c'est une question 16 il faut
pas qu'ils aient trop de dispersion au
premier tour sinon il peut y avoir
effectivement un 21 avril comme en 2002
et il est important que le changement en
france la justice sociale le progrès
passent par le seul candidat qui peut le
mettre en oeuvre une fois élu c'est
françois hollande
mais j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
autres candidatures de gauche ça veut
dire que leurs voix leurs idées ne sont
pas importants mais je pense que
effectivement la candidature de françois
hollande est une candidature de
rassemblement et ont aimé le premier
tour moi je vous interroger sur marine
le pen qu'est ce que vous répondez
ce serait une déflagration si elle
n'avait pas ses 500 signatures les aura
son appareil à chaque fois ce que je
crois c'est que dans la crise parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui souffrent
parce qu'à une perte de confiance parce
que nicolas sarkozy a aussi beaucoup
divisé les français et brouiller les
repères moraux de la france je pense
qu'il y a pour l'extrême droite un
terrain favorable et que c'est très
mauvais pour la société française c'est
très mauvais pour les classes populaires
que madame le pen tente de convaincre et
donc je pense que c'est un danger pour
la france tout entière
néanmoins il faut qu'elle soit candidate
je pense que vous pensez qu'elle veut
sur wii mais je suis pas pour lutter
contre des idées que je rejette par la
censure ou par l'interdiction de porter
ses idées
je suis pour que la raison la conviction
permettent de voir quels sont les
chemins efficace pour justement sortir
des grandes difficultés dans les canaux
sommes bertand delanoë donc on a compris
de l'importance de la candidature de
françois hollande vous avez regardé les
derniers sondages il y à un effritement
de la position du candidat socialiste
alors on lui reproche de choses
apparemment contradictoires un manque
d'allant d'initiative et puis
aujourd'hui cette forte polémique autour
de son
initiative concernant la réforme du
quotient familial d'abord sur ce dernier
point quel est votre avis il est réformé
comme le propose le candidat socialiste
qui dit maintenant qu'il veut le module
et le quotient familial oui ou non
d'abord faisait une allusion sont
d'arrêt je crois que c'est très bon pour
françois hollande
à trois mois du premier tour j'avais m à
28% et que dans tous les sondages second
tour il à 54,57 donc on sait que trois
mois avant le scrutin
c'est une position vraiment valable et
que bien sûr quand on lui donnait 35% au
premier tour où 60% second tour c'était
l'effet des primaires la sympathique
avait suscité notre manière de faire son
plan de la démocratie sur le quotient
familial
lefrançois l'homme n'est pas candidat
pour que rien ne change il est candidat
pour qu'il y ait plus de justice dans
les politiques menées dans ce pays
donc effectivement il veut une politique
familiale une politique d' aide aux
parents pour les enfants
il veut simplement la répartir justement
actuellement grâce à ce qu'on ce
quotient familial
les ménages les plus favorisés reçoivent
le plus c'est quelqu'un qui a dix mille
euros par mois il reçoit environ 2000
euros par enfant celui qui n'est pas
imposable qui est donc plus besoin sans
rien et celui qui est dans les classes
moyennes autour de 4000 euros lui alors
il reçoit beaucoup moins donc que veut
faire françois hollande a comme le dit
l'article lui même s'est exprimé
clairement il veut qu' il y ait cette
politique familiale
mais que ce soit égalitaire c'est à dire
que chaque enfant de france reçoivent le
même avantage que vous soyez au smic que
vous soyez classes moyennes basses
classes moyennes supérieures ou même
riche vous recevrez la même chose par
cette fiscalité par cette réforme
fiscale pour élever vos enfants c'est
quand même beaucoup plus juste de donner
plus parce que c'est ça avec monsieur
sarkozy on donne plus à ceux qui ont le
plus de moyens
et moins ou rien à ceux qui ont moins de
moyens car nicolas sarkozy que vous
citez lui annonce des conséquences
désastreuses de cette réforme du
quotient familial et à droite à l'ump on
se donne le mot on dit que françois
hollande veut assassiner les classes
moyennes et démolir la politique
familiale dans notre ville foyer de moi
sarkozy pendant cinq ans n'a cessé de
diviser la france est de l'affaiblir
regarder dans quelle situation nous
sommes dans quelle situation sont des
services publics le chômage et il n'a
cessé d'électriser les relations entre
les français et la démocratie transall
en pagne en campagne mais attendez ça a
été pendant cinq ans hélas trois mois
avant l'élection avec une désinvolture
une brutalité un cynisme lui ses amis de
l'ump ne cesse d'électriser et
d'abaisser le débat des débats
démocratiques manière en publiant chaque
fois qu'un concurrent dit quelque chose
c'est un jeu de massacre
mais c'est pas ça la démocratie la
démocratie ce d'un affrontement tout à
fait tonique c'est un affrontement avec
des contradictions
nous on se respecte d'abord je pense que
nicolas sarkozy qui est quand même le
président sortant il manque de respect
aux français il manque de respect aux
français quand il ment il manque de
respect aux français quand ils creusent
les inégalités sociales il manque de
respect aux français quand ils les
divise
le président de la république c'est
normal qu'il ait des convictions c'est
normal qu'il est une politique de droite
ou de gauche
1001 devoir suprême l'unité de la nation
et l'unité de la nation elle ne se fait
pas en stigmatisant les uns et les
autres et elle peut même mieux se faire
par la justice sociale et une forme de
maîtrise comparer le profil personnel de
nicolas sarkozy et de françois hollande
nicolas sarkozy tout temps dans la table
dans le conflit et c'est françois est un
homme serein qui a la maîtrise du temps
et que la maîtrise de son propos et de
sa campagne pourra tenir le choc dans
cette campagne le défi privé moi je suis
assez content de la manière dont ils
procèdent parce que je ne crois
c'est le spectacle médiatique qui fait
le résultat d'une élection c'est ce que
les gens ressentent pour leur vie réelle
que possible maintenant les monsieur
aussi incertain évitement des sujets
vent me posais déjà abattu évitement des
sujets oui c'est françois hollande
qu'elle ait lancé le thème de la réforme
fiscale c'est françois hollande qui a
lancé le thème de l'éducation
c'est françois hollande qui a relancé le
thème de la jeunesse c'est françois
hollande qui parle du service public
notamment de la santé hélas aujourd'hui
de la politique familiale juste mais
effectivement il n'est pas dans ce
spectacle médiatique
je trouve qu'il a une certaine maîtrise
et de son comportement et du temps et
nous en reparlerons dans trois mois nous
en reparlerons en trois mois
même avant car j'ai l'impression que les
français verront la cohérence tout est
un parfait on va pas rentrer au paradis
si françois hollande est élu président
de la république c'est difficile on est
en crise les finances publiques sont en
miettes
grâce à monsieur sarkozy si j'ose dire
pas seulement pas seulement il a comme
atout selon il a quand même selon la
cour des comptes creuser les deux tiers
de la dette supplémentaire depuis cinq
ans c'est quand même énorme je suis
gestionnaire
je gère un budget de 7 milliards d'euros
par an aux si vous surveillez votre note
triple a d'ailleurs à la mairie mais
vous savez que les agences ont dit que
je la garderai que je méritais de la
garde et sauf si la france la perdre et
parce qu'il n'était pas possible que la
capitale les sens serait trop vexatoires
sans doute alors le gouvernement du pays
bertrand delaunay qui était quelle
fougue et l'engouement populaire pour
françois hollande vous qui avez soutenu
martine aubry vous l'avez vous découvert
là depuis qu'il est temps d'une
profession investi si monsieur gossio
vous avez bien suivi la campagne des
primeurs g structure martine aubry par
conviction pour un certain nombre de
raisons que j'ai exprimée à ce moment là
j'ai jamais dit de mal de françois
hollande qui a toujours été un ami et
que j'ai soutenu pendant 11 ans quand
été premier secrétaire il y a eu les
primaires elles sont finis je pense que
françois hollande a une intelligence
politique qui le met à la hauteur de la
gravité de la situation
c'est un homme qui a des convictions et
surtout pour en avoir parlé avec lui je
sais qu'il est conscient de
du mal-être du pays aujourd'hui et de la
lourdeur de la tâche qui l'attend et ça
c'est fondamental
alors vous êtes tranche avec nous et
sarkozy d'accord alors nicolas sarkozy
vous l'avait critiquée pour ses attaques
sa façon de faire dans la campagne
comment est ce que vous avez apprécié
alors la charge de françois fillon cette
fois qui s'en est pris à la scorpionique
de françois hollande sa diabolisation
infantile et sans catastrophisme
rustique monsieur françois fillon aimera
bonne réputation d'homme sage bien
propre sur lui et en fait c'est un bon
sarkozyste c'est à dire que au moment où
il faut être violent cynique que prendre
des libertés avec la vérité
il y va carrément bon c'est une forme
d'héritage d'une forme non pas du
gaullisme mais du rpr qui était comme ça
un peu violent un peu sectaire et je
pense que ça ne leur réussira pas et
donc je crois qu'il faut que nous nous
continuons avec sérénité mais
combativité a développé des arguments et
être inspiré par la vie des français je
crois que monsieur sarkozy est président
depuis cinq ans je sais que c'est un
très bon candidat
les français savent qu'il a été un très
mauvais président vous interroger sur le
premier ministre françois fillon parce
qu'on se dit que si demain il est
candidat à la mairie de paris un bon
vous vous êtes peut-être plus là a
priori ça sera un sacré combattant un je
serai là mais je ne serai pas candidat
et c'est pas parce que si elle lui est
cher mission ce n'est pas parce que je
ne ferais pas candidat que étant là je
ne ferai pas efficace et monsieur
fillion est un homme respectable
je crois qu'il ne correspond pas
absolument pas à ce don tombes ont
besoin les parisiens dans l'avenir non
je pense qu'il ya une culture politique
et une culture urbaine qui est datée
alors que les parisiens depuis 11 ans
ont vraiment ensemble fin chemin vers le
progrès et l'innovation
cette culture urbaine qui remet en cause
des schémas anciens et que de ce point
de vue là monsieur fillon est assez
décalé par rapport qui comprennent une
partie de l'électorat de droite
parisiens y va être investi pour les
législatives à naître à l'ump
posé la question et c'est moi qui les
avais regardées à l'espagne dans le clan
ben ali mais bon ce sera par exemple une
défaite pour rachida dati que vous
connaissez je suis socialiste je suis
pas consultés donc je vais pas faire de
commentaires là dessus a voulu mêler pas
sévère sur je ne m'arrête pas françois
fillon qui lui consacre ses voeux à la
france hier en tant que premier ministre
à démolir le candidat socialiste ce que
je trouve pas très classe pour dire la
vérité
allez on va accueillir corinne delpech
de l' agence france-presse mais avant
cela bertrand delanoë on va tenter de
comprendre pourquoi en ayant gagné à
deux reprises cette fameuse bataille de
paris
vous n'avez pas enregistré de victoire
au sein même du parti socialiste qu'elle
est donc faux emprunte aujourd'hui au
sein du parti socialiste que vous avez
rejoindre j'étais très jeune maire de
paris eurs barré est pas candidat à
présent on regarde l'anc est saigné
monnyer souci au parti socialiste le
parcours de bertrand delanoë est
jalonnée de tour de force et de rendez
vous manqués le plus marquant ce produit
au congrès de reims en 2008
bien placé pour s'installer dans le
fauteuil de premier secrétaire
un move à lui barrer la route dans un
livre écrit avec laurent joffrin il se
définit comme socialiste et libéral le
terme est lâché
il ne pourra plus se défaire en ses
adversaires ont utilisé ça contre lui et
laurent lui à accrocher quelque sorte
une casserole ova idéologique et je
pense que ça va je n'ai ensuite dans ses
rapports avec les militants qui était à
l'époque le corps électoral qui devait
désigner le futur premier secrétaire
affaibli il se rallie finalement à
martine aubry un manque de sens
politique pour ses adversaires mais
selon ses proches c'est au contraire la
marque d'un sens aigu des
responsabilités
ce n'est pas un homme d'appareil ce pas
un homme qui va décider en fonction de
l'intérêt de tel ou tel
outre son intérêt c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui voit d'abord l'intérêt
général il ya toujours parfois même un
regard un peu condescendant des
apparatchiks à son égard parce que
sûrement il est déstabilisé
ce n'est pas du tout dans ce registre là
bertrand delanoë dit oui au pouvoir mais
pas à n'importe quel prix politique
n'est pas tout pour lui d'ailleurs il
l'avait abandonnée puis là il a repris
ensuite et donc il a une expérience il
n'est pas entièrement dédiés ou dévoué à
la vie politique
il était une personnalité à mon avis
plus riche que ça une attitude qui
expliquerait sa popularité
bertrand delanoë ne quitte plus le
podium des personnalités politiques
préférées des français depuis près d'une
décennie
absente de l'organigramme de campagne de
françois hollande
il annonce qu'il ne briguera pas de
troisième mandat de maire dans la
capitale françois fillon cécile duflot
se positionne pour 2014 bertrand delanoë
sera t-il rester à l'écart de cette
nouvelle bataille de paris
vous l'avez dit se battre avec
conviction sans se battre pour son
ambition
le premier on a vu françois hollande à
jarnac dans les meetings il ressemble à
françois mitterrand il un peu sa
gestuelle
est-ce que c'est pas une référence un
peu désuète 16 ans après la mort du seul
président socialiste lors françois
hollande n'est pas françois mitterrand
françois hollande et françois hollande
il a ses propres qualités que françois
mitterrand soit une référence pour nous
tous le seul président de la république
socialiste celui qui a marqué la france
l'histoire de la france je pense que
c'est tout à fait naturel
en revanche voit un point commun entre
françois mitterrand et françois hollande
c'est une certaine maîtrise du temps et
des événements il ne cède pas à la
pression
aucun des deux n'a le goût du spectacle
médiatique et du superficiel ils sont
pas paillettes et strass
ils sont pas le genre du fouquet's est
plutôt la france profonde et une win
certaine relation à ce qui est important
et ce qui est secondaire
alors quelles sont leurs grandes
différences emballages la période
le parcours vous savez ceux qui sont nés
avant la guerre de 40 avant l'occupation
avant le nazisme
avant la résistance et ceux qui n'ont
sont nés après dont je fais partie comme
françois hollande ne peuvent pas avoir
la même le même parcours politique la
même formation
françois comme moi a dû être
impressionné par les conquêtes lente
douloureuse des forces populaires des
forces progressistes dans la vème
république n'oubliez pas que la gauche a
mis 23 ans pour trouver sa légitimité et
c'était en 1980 avec françois mitterrand
voilà je pense qu'il a été formé comme
ça c'est d'un homme moderne est ce que
vous considérez qu'il a dissipé le flou
que lui reprochait martine aubry que
vous souteniez à la primaire voyez les
mêmes arguments que martin que je
soutenais évidemment face à françois que
je ne critiquerai pas parce que je le
connais bien je l'apprécient même si ce
n'était pas lui que j'avais choisi dans
la primaire pour le reste je pense que
françois veux être clair sur quelques
dossiers essentiels
la france est vraiment sale état et le
président de la république n'est pas
comme monsieur sarkozy celui qui veut
être ministre de tous les secteurs
il doit prendre de la hauteur et
orienter la politique de la france dans
quelques domaines essentiels genre
appelé tout à l'heure avec monsieur
grossiord il y en aura d'autres la
campagne commence à peine et vous verrez
que sans se disperser sans essayer de
faire un catalogue
il y aura une identification de françois
hollande a de grandes orientations
illustrer concrètement tient tout à
l'heure en parler logement
françois hollande lui s'engagera sur
l'encadrement des loyers
c'est fondamental pour une énorme
majorité de français dont vous verrez
qu'il sera identifiée à des points très
précis mais il va pas se disperser et
c'est pas le rôle du président de la
république alors vous avez dit que vous
seriez dans la campagne mais quel sera
votre rôle exact que je suis là voyez je
fais déjà beaucoup de monde mais pas
oui mais je suis dans le conseil
politique restreint c'est à dire je
crois une dizaine ou une quinzaine de
personnes que françois réunis pour
échanger avec eux qui se font soit me
l'a demandé
et de toute façon françois c'est que je
fais campagne à paris vous avez un
million trois cent mille électeurs c'est
un peu importants il ya surtout trois
cent mille électeurs de plus qu'il ya
dix ans et puis quand on en parlait avec
france on disait je souhaite qu'on se
parle politique donc dans ce conseil
politique restera et puis que tu fasses
des médias et puis que faire des
meetings me disait-il
voilà quand il aura besoin vous savez
avec moi c'est simple d'abord parce que
notre relation est très sereine et
amicales entre vous à un moment il vous
avez soutenir ainsi vous avez soutenu
martine aubry aux primaires
il n'y a pas eu un petit éloignement on
en a parlé avec françois je pense qu'il
aurait préféré que je le soutienne
et je pense qu'il a apprécié que je sois
aussi correcte et amicale à son égard
pendant la primaire
est ce que vous le voyez ce fait les je
voudrais vous dire une autre chose c'est
que pour françois je suis commode parce
que j'ai rien à demander je pas
perturbateurs jeu pendant les jeux de
pouvoir donc il peut m'utiliser
quand il aura besoin je suis libre je
suis indépendant et je crois que il a
besoin de quelques personnes aussi
qu'ils ne sont pas concernés par des
rivalités de pouvoir tout à fait normal
dans la société humaine et dans la vie
politique est une ambition en cas
d'alternance pendant quelques mois j'ai
beaucoup d'ambitions pour réussir mes 13
ans la mairie de paris je vais bientôt
en avoir fait onze ans et je suis j'ai
beaucoup d'ambitions pour que françois
réussisse son quinquennat donc il ya
plein de manières de l'aider et y
compris que maire de paris puis on verra
bien je n'ai pas si vous voulez laurent
joffrin le disais j'ai un rapport à la
politique qui n'est pas un rapport de
dépendance que j'ai beaucoup d'ambitions
vais relire comme j'ai beaucoup
d'ambition mais je ne suis pas drogué je
ne suis pas dépendants comme autant de
ré sa politique donc voilà mais comme
vous l'avez remarqué depuis 40 ans je
suis quand même particulièrement engagée
vous avez vu un grand moment
démocratique dans ce pays sans que je
sois totalement engagé comme hélas les
questions étaient pressés sur vos
ambitions abonnement est ce que vous
aimeriez être ministre mais si vous
l'êtes ministre de quoi non je souhaite
vraiment être maire de paris jusqu'à
c'est pas je souhaite compatibles ah si
je pratique pas le cumul des mandats on
verra à écouter ils sont déjà des envies
mais c'est gentil de me poser la
question serait gentil d'écouter la
réponse avons envie d'entrer ou de
rester bien et que vous savez que je
suis sincère à j'ai vraiment envie de
réussir la tâche que je dois accomplir
que je dois aux parisiens jusqu'à 2014
mais en même temps je vais des françois
président autant que possible pour
l'aider comme président il faut d'abord
l'être comme candidat après c'est pour
aider la france mais pas ce que c'est
mais à nice et ma famille ce sont mes
convictions je n'ai pas de plan de
carrière je n'en ai jamais eu vous savez
vous avez été témoin de ma campagne pour
la candidature à la candidature à la
mairie de paris
vous savez que je fonctionne par
conviction par ambition 1 avec la
volonté de prendre des responsabilités
mais que j'ai pas un plan de carrière
classement nous le propose
notre gouvernement resserré oui je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait de raison à court
terme pour que cette question se pose à
bon ici à une supposée honnêtement je
vous assure je vous dirai pas d'abord je
suis maire de paris oui donc c'est quand
même dans la balance
deuxièmement quelle que soit ma réponse
je serai capable de dire aux françaises
et aux français
les motivations de la réponse je suis de
ce point de vue là à un moment de ma vie
où rien ne me gênent pour dire aux
citoyens ce qui me motivait pourquoi je
prends tel ou tel que ce sont des pros
pour voir monsieur grossiord comprenez
que la politique ça peut être beaucoup
d'engagement beaucoup de
désintéressement beaucoup de 2,2
d'implication et qu'on n'est pas obligé
de le lier à sa personne de temps
peut-être que ma situation est facilitée
par le fait que j'exerce une mission
extrêmement importante qui me vient du
suffrage universel et que j'aime
arrive alors il ya peut-être un conseil
que vous pourriez prodigués à la france
aux relances vous avez expérimenter en
grandeur réelle
le gouvernement avec les verts avec les
verts n'ont jamais les amis de jean luc
mélenchon dans la majorité
bravo donc vous dit souhaiter voulu
souhaiter bien du plaisir avec les verts
dans un gouvernement de gauche
il faut que les socialistes acceptent
qu'ils ont des partenaires nous avons
des partenaires et la gauche est
beaucoup plus forte de ces différences
mais il faut avoir l'esprit de
responsabilité pour être solidaire donc
c'est pas un conseil que je donne à
françois parce qu'il sait tout cela
mais c'est vrai que dirigeant de
majorité depuis 11 ans dans la plus
grande collectivité française où il ne
manque aucune des facettes de toutes les
composantes de la gauche
je crois que nous réussissons quand nous
savons nous écouter nous respecter
savoir que tout le monde a des idées
tout à fait intéressante mais que la
seule chose qui compte c'est ce que nous
faisons ensemble et ce sera pareil pour
le pays
alors est il ya une verte importantes
qui arrivent à paris où est ce qu'on en
est d'ailleurs est-ce que vous allez
soutenir danièle hoffman rispal dans la
circonscription que brigue cécile duflot
ou bien est-ce que vous la laisserai
faire sa campagne the grocer a fait
allusion à un différend très sérieux que
j'ai eu avec martine aubry je le
regrette
oui le mot de trop fortes non je
regrette qu'il ait lieu mais bon je ne
regrette pas d'avoir des clans et
maintenant vous permettez je vais vous
dire que si je les fais alors que ça me
peine c'est parce qu'il y a des valeurs
des convictions une culture démocratique
à paris que vous connaissez bien avec
lesquels je ne peux pas je ne dois pas
prêt à transiger
nous avons rénové la vie démocratique à
paris n'oubliez pas que la vie
démocratique à paris avant 2001 c'est un
parti c'était l'esprit d'appareils qui
avaient envahi paris est donc une forme
d'authenticité de proximité de non cumul
des mandats
les parisiens après si je ne cumule pas
les mandats y compris dans le temps donc
que ce soit un parachutage socialiste
madame ou un parachutage verts j'aurais
eu la même réaction
actuellement je ne m'occupe que de
élection de françois hollande les
élections législatives c'est après la
présidence et encore alors le
parachutage de soins du la sks à dire
qu'il faut être né quelque part on a le
droit de faire et je suis en tunisie et
j'ai vécu dans l'aveyron alors pas là
cécile duflot leur exemple je vais vous
donner un exemple mon adjoint denis
baupin adjoint vert denis baupin
il a fait le tour de france part lors de
la bretagne et que ça finalement il est
candidat à paris est ce que julie c'est
aurait dû commencer par là puisque tu
adjoint au maire de paris depuis onze
ans bon voilà il ya il ya quelque chose
aujourd'hui qui est vrai dans tous les
partis regardez c'est vrai à droite
c'est vrai dans tous les partis de
gauche
les citoyens ont envie d'une relation de
proximité d'authenticité
c'est pas le fait d'être né à paris
quant à jack
quant à jack sont arrivés mais dans les
enjeux touchent le comtal écoutez moi je
constate deux choses d'abord une bête
candidats à la suite d'un vote unanime
les militants parce qu'il a cédé 108 a
fait il a refusé terminé militants dis
pas que je peux terminer monsieur
grossiord et ça fait penser à une autre
radio
bon on interrompt beaucoup donc un des
militants unanime visera là on a envie
que notre candidat deuxièmement c'est
une circonscription détenue par un
député de droite aujourd'hui donc il va
aller essayer de prendre pour la gauche
une circonscription détenue par la
droite
c'est quand même mieux que de se
parachuter dans un endroit où on n'a
aucun lien et où sa famille politique
les 70 ans pour ce serait quand même
préciser que le challenge n'est pas le
même vous ne laisserez quand même
préciser que jack lang a refusé le de se
soumettre au vote des militants du pas
de calais comme un poids de précis alors
mais j'ai l'impression est franchement
bertrand delanoë que vous appréciez plus
le geste de françoise de panafieu qui
fut votre grande adversaire à paris qui
elle a décidé de passer la main plutôt
que jack lang qui s'accroche à 72 heures
je me trompe d'abord je compare pas
françoise de panafieu et jack lang
mais c'est vrai que j'ai dit à françoise
de panafieu que je trouvais que son
geste avait de la classe
d'autant que en même temps qu'elle
passait la main elle disait je souhaite
qu'une femme soit élue et que dans la
famille ump
le grand problème c'est qu'il risque d'y
avoir aucune femme députée ump
à paris et donc voilà avec madame de
panafieu c'est combattu on est très
différents
bon elle m'a pas ménagé je crois qu'à
une époque j'étais ringard ou un truc
comme ça mais c'est pas grave la vie
passée on leur dit tous et j'ai une
certaine considération pour elle
d'ailleurs on soit bientôt parce que je
trouve que ce qu'elle a fait était assez
classe sont durs et chapeau dernière
question qu'on se libère et rivaux à
londres pour les jeux olympiques que
votre ville a failli organisée je sers
mon coeur
non je ne vis pas dans le regret voyez
par exemple moi je plie mise tout je
veux dit finalement là le quartier de
batignolles on l'a ménages plus vite
parce qu'on n'a pas à passer par l'étape
village olympique je voulais avant les
jeux olympiques évidemment bon on les a
pas assez longue tant mieux +2 oui bien
sûr c'est tant mieux pour eux je
souhaite il les réussit ce que ce soit
un moment de sport et de valeurs et pas
seulement le fric et voilà mais je pense
que c'est une belle a beau défi pour les
londoniens vous verrez je suis moins
proche de l'actuel maire boris johnson
que je ne l'étais lui merck a gagné les
jeux mon ami ken livingstone oui si les
circonstances s'y prêtent
si on me convient j'irai de très bon
coeur il assure y compris pour leur dire
que voilà c'est tout ça va être des
compétition fraternelle et vous ne vous
dit jamais si j'avais gagné je mets mon
sens politique aurait été totalement
différent et peut-être que je sais moi
qui serai candidat à l'elysée qui cette
vie comme ça je me le dit pas comme ça
même c'est quand laurent joffrin a parlé
tout à l'heure de mon raisonnement sur
le libéralisme politique contre le
libéralisme économique
aujourd'hui vous interrogez n'importe
quel candidat de gauche il est obligé
d'être d'accord avec ce que j'ai dit
dans le livre mais à l'époque on a voulu
me caricaturer avec l'appui des médias
d'ailleurs mais surtout mes concurrents
politiques pour faire battre bo battu
c'est la vie ces jeux je ne pleure pas
sur le lait renversé
je ne suis pas narcissique au point de
pleurer sur moi j'aime mon pays et
voilà je préfère être dans une dynamique
joyeuse et et d'être heureux oui de
soutenir quelqu'un que j'apprécie qui
s'appelle françois sarr la période aucun
d'autres elles sont plus là c'est pas
moi à son âge et cela dit vous voulez
extremis la vie n'est pas terminée je
veux dire peut-être que je pouvais
encore rendre quelques services
même si je ne le programme pas très bien
on va attendre encore une fois alors
vous pourriez dire par exemple de francs
soit hollande qu'il est comme vous
socialiste et libéral parce que vous
nous dites aujourd'hui françois ne
dirait pas comme ça après mais on vous
le dit pour lui autant d après ce qui
m'est arrivé à mon avis ils ne diront
pas comme ça mais lisez ce que j'ai
écrit dans l'air je me souviens même que
j'ai que c'était contre le libéralisme
économique
j'étais pour la liberté l'épanouissement
avait lieu au sens philosophique du
terme
le libéralisme politique et laurent
joffrin le 10ème alors vous êtes social
libéral ne surtout pas bon donc
philosophiquement nous devons être assez
d'accord françois et moi mais je ne veux
pas lui faire de balle merci encore une
fois
corinne perrine tarneaud de public sénat
va nous rejoindre on va s'intéresser
donc à paris bertrand delanoë puisque
c'est presque l'heure du bilan vous
installez on peut le dire votre première
adjointe anne hidalgo dans un processus
de succession et côté ce reportage dans
les rues de paris signé aïda caire
courage bertrand delanoë l'a déclaré pas
de troisième mandat en 2014
après jacques chirac et jean tiberi les
parisiens font le bilan du maire
socialiste
il y à du positif pas mal de changements
dans l'urbain il ya autolib valides qui
marche pas mal le fait que la ville ce
soir est approprié les la gestion des
eaux
je pense notamment à cet événement
annuel qu'est la nuit blanche il y à du
négatif il n'a pas fait autre chose que
ça pour la culture la nuit blanche c'est
un peu c'est un peu un faux semblants et
je pense qu'il aurait pu faire plus de
choses pour que notre ville soit
vachement plus active et à bas les
loyers ça explose je sais pas si les
gens encore rendu l'argent pour pouvoir
louer sa robe beaucoup moins bien sûr
trouver mon scooter
voilà je n'avance plus les trottoirs
sont dégueulasses les couloirs bus oui
c'est l'horreur femme bien pour les bus
moins bien pour ceux qui roulent en
voiture paris plage voilà paris plages
paris plages et il ya aussi du
comparatif aubin chirac avait été
beaucoup plus flamboyant beaucoup plus
dynamique et puis on voyait que chirac
avait d'autres ambitions
c'était un tremplin comme pour tout et
lui laisser son empreinte et un souci
dans quelle direction regarder le
chapitre des transports reste toujours
polémique moi ya surtout eu le tramway
qui a échangé avec les nouvelles lignes
qui ont été agrandis il ya surtout une
chose que j'espère qu'il ne va pas faire
c'est fermer les voies sur berge
définitivement parce que ça c'est nul
nul nul ce qu alors là bonjour alors ou
alors faut supprimer les voitures dans
paris voilà perrine tarneaud nous a
rejoint bonsoir perrine bonsoir bertrand
effectivement pourtant les voies sur
berge entre or c'est le quai branly
elles vont bien fermé non d'ici l'été
bien sûr bazar en partie seulement se
rassurer c'est à dire que c'est
seulement entre le musée d'orsay le pont
de l'alma sur la rive gauche qu'elle
renfermait et sur la rive droite seront
réaménagés mais y aura autant de place
pour les voitures simplement sera un
petit peu plus civilisé et pourtant on a
vu là les deux trois derniers jours
quand ces voies sur berges étaient
fermées à cause de la crue de la seine
les nombreux embouteillages que ça
engendre et dans les problèmes quand on
a fait le tramway d'abord parce qu'il
faut que les automobilistes s'habituent
au changement d'itinéraire
deuxièmement il y a eu que 5 à 10
minutes perdues entre la gare
d'austerlitz et la tour eiffel ce qui
est pas con sierra mais je le prends au
sérieux
et troisièmement il y aura une nouvelle
voie pour les voitures faites sur le
quai où entre le musée d'orsay et la
place de la concorde
elle n'existe pas actuellement
avant la fermeture des voies sur berge
ce que je voudrais dire parce que je
comprends paris une île démocratique ont
des bas mais il y a moins 25% de voiture
à paris est question pollution c'est
moins 80% me site de carbone - 80% de
benzène -9% de gaz à effet de serre et
-32% de pollution de proximité faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
je crois effectivement que la ville
dense ça concerne pas que paris c'est
toutes les grandes villes de france et
du monde
il doit y avoir moins de véhicules
individuels polluants et c'est pour que
soit pour cela qu'avec 40 collectivités
locales voisines
on a créé autolib de manière à ce qu'on
puisse avoir de temps entre une voiture
mais on la partage
elle n'est pas polluante vous verrez que
dans quelques années ça aura beaucoup
changé les mentalités y compris parce
que ça sera moins cher d'utiliser
autolib que de posséder sa voiture mais
justement autoliv
un mois après sa mise en service que
vous n'êtes pas un peu déçu par quelques
cafouillages autour de cette mise en
service elle ferait il y avait peu de
voitures on en voit très peu d'en parler
parce que le choix qui a été fait c'est
de monter en puissance sur un an
c'est à dire qu'on a commencé le 1er
décembre mais le service ne sera complet
que fin décembre 2012 aujourd'hui moi je
vais d'accélérer une attitude non non
non non non on a lancé à l'appel
d'offres les choses étaient claires
moi je dis il vaut mieux le faire plus
tard et que d'entrer tout soit prêt mais
aussi bien dans mon équipe que les
industriels etc
tout le monde me disait non c'est trop
compliqué c'est trop innovant ça n'a été
fait nulle part il faut qu'on puisse le
faire de manière progressive y compris
pour corriger nos propres erreurs au fur
et à mesure moi vous savez je suis pas
quelqu'un contrairement à ce qu'on est
je suis autoritaire mais je suis pas
borné et donc fermé vous êtes et
autoritaire oui eh ben vous savez je
crois que pour diriger paris vaut mieux
avoir un peu d'autorité bien et donc
voilà et je pense qu'on a fait ce choix
il faut l'optimiser
c'est une efficacité qui est progressive
qui se fait par étapes donc le jugement
sur auto libre on pourra le faire fin
bertrand delanoë
votre réaction ce soir cette information
de l'équipe le quotidien sportif avec
cette hypothèse de détruire l'actuel
parc des princes pour en reconstruire un
tout neuf sur le même site en vue de
l'euro 2016
d'abord je souhaite que le psg qui dans
la compétition européenne soient jugés
comme les autres grands clubs parce que
on ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie sur
l'économie certaines ambitions avant
même le stade
il ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie dans les
commentaires tout le monde veut qu'on
soit en compétition avec le barça et il
paye les joueurs encore plus cher bon
voilà le foot maintenant que d'un grand
sport c'est aussi une économie une
certaine dimension
deuxièmement je trouve normal que le psg
veut y avoir un beau stade moderne de 50
60 min à ce problème
le problème c'est que dans le parc
actuel on peut pas aller au delà de 50
puis l'on peut faire très très beau très
moderne excellent mais cinquante mille
que pour faire plus de 50000 il faudrait
le démolir
je pense que la question de la
démolition d'une question extrêmement
difficile en termes de possibles en
termes de possibles en termes de saisies
n'ont certainement pas du tout est il
possible de détruire le parc des princes
il fait partie du patrimoine
architectural de paris certains vous
diront qu'il est très meuble qu'il est
très bon voire n'est pas question et il
y à un architecte que je respecte
beaucoup qu'il a rénovée qui est
monsieur taillibert bon donc je crois
que sont les questions lourdes et par
rapport à ces questions lors je n'ai pas
le droit d'être irresponsable j'ai
l'expérience des changements urbain à
paris et je sais que chaque fois qu'on
veut changer quelque chose
bon c'est compliqué donc je pense que ce
qui est souhaitable c'est que le psg
grandes équipes européennes est un stade
magnifique au parc des princes de 50000
places sans démolir l'enveloppent
suffisant 50000 places le qatar qui la
maison
non mais plutôt 70 mille plateaux
secrète à la même manière les autres
grands clubs européens il faut deux
choses d'abord se dire que la force du
psg dans les dix ans qui viennent ce
sera ses résultats sportifs son image de
ma forme était là pression non mais
attendez ils les ont déjà jugé très
content et son champion d'automne bon
enfin il ajouté moins brillante
oui mais attendez de ce sport c'est
comme ça donc je les aime beaucoup je
les soutiens à fond je pense que pour
être les meilleurs dans les années qui
viennent en europe c'est ça leur
ambition et c'est mon ambition
je pense qu'il leur faut un stade une
maison où il ya une identité fort il
faut qu'il soit chez eux chez leurs
supporters c'est le parc des princes il
je serais ravi que ce soit soixante
mille places mais je pense que les dix
milles d'écart sont pas si importante
que ça mais en revanche c'est vrai qu'il
faut qu'il soit dans le stade ultra
moderne
je doute quand même un petit élément
c'est que si ronald rénove le parc tel
qu'il est on est prêt pour l'euro 2016
si on ne démolit c'est pour faire un
stade de 60000 70000 n'y aurait pas de
match à paris serait quand même embêtant
il compris pour le psg soutien et y
compris pour les propriétaires qui
organise la coupe du monde en 2020 mais
mené pendant les travaux le psg va quand
même déménagé au sein de francs dont
vous n'avez pas peur que le pg prennent
goût à un grand stade à la hauteur
d'oublier c'est que ce n'est pas la
mairie de paris qui va financer les
travaux de rénovation les travaux de
rénovation vont être financés par le
consortium qui a gagné l'appel d'offres
et dans lequel il y a évidemment le psg
et c'est eux qui vont financer
je pars à 110 120 à 130 millions d'euros
de travaux
donc s'ils financent ces travaux ce sera
pas pour s'installer définitivement au
stade de france d'amour est ce qu'on
peut envisager un psg sans aucune
subvention municipale comme le demandent
certains élus parisiens de votre
position oui mais oui monsieur l'amour
et monsieur goasguen ont voté autour du
15 décembre la subvention psg et le 18
ils ont dit faudrait supprimer les en
déloger
monsieur l'amour a découvert l'économie
foot allons allons allons ça c'est de là
vraiment c'est pas bien de faire de la
politique comme ça
deuxièmement je veux dire aux
téléspectateurs que la subvention ne
contribuent absolument pas au
fonctionnement du club
elle sert pour l'équipe féminine pour
les clubs filleuls pour la formation et
pour voilà tout un tas d'initiatives de
lien entre l'équipe et les parisiens
deuxièmement elle était de 6 millions
d'euros par an quand monsieur l'amour
les amis musulmans de lattes et
conseiller du maire donc voyez il est
intelligent le contenu d'un million non
elle est un peu moins d'un million et on
l'a baissé donc qu'est ce que je veux
dire
on peut discuter du mont tauch normal
puisque j'ai moi même baissé mais je ne
veux pas qu'on j'aimerais qu'on ne
discute pas du principe parce que le
principe c'est le lien entre la ville de
paris et son équipe de foot et ça c'est
une histoire c'est une âme et donc je
pense que ce lien qui passe par les
clubs filleuls qui passe par la
formation qui passe par les quartiers ça
serait dommage de l'abîmé
il reste deux minutes y'a tellement que
dossier parisien oui je sais plus par
quoi commencer vous faites du logement
aura priorité en 2012 et vous ne voulez
que je suis ben oui spécialement vous
l'avait dit pour l'année 2012 vous
souhaitez créer une autorité de
métropolitaine la compétente sur ce
dossier pourtant il existe le grand
paris est ce que ça c'est pas le bon
cadre pour le jeu je me rends pas fait
quelque chose on va produire des cinq
corps le président de la république
parle du grand paris il ya un dossier
sur lequel ça avance et je le reconnais
loyalement grâce au président de région
jean paul huchon c'est les transports
tout le reste n'a pas avancé en matière
de logement ce sont les communes qui
font vraiment le logement social mais il
ya des communes qui refusent donc moi je
propose effectivement qu'on discute les
élus locaux de droite et de gauche de la
métropole
qu'on discute d'une autorité régulatrice
de logements qui une vraie compétence de
manière à traiter de cette question du
logement dans la zone dense ensemble de
manière volontariste une question sur le
futur toit des halles de paris ce qu'on
appelle la canopée ce grand toit en
verre son marché a été annulé par le
tribunal
administratives parce que la canopée été
jugé trop cher et ce qu'il faut revoir
ce toit de verre est ce que ça va
retarder annulé le chantier le tribunal
administratif nous a dit qu'il y avait
un dépassement dont nous allons nous
mettre en règle par rapport à ce que
nous demande le tribunal explique anne
ministre hâtif mais nous ne sommes pas
d'accord nous faisons appel
je précise que le préfet de région dont
on me dit qu'il est pressenti pour être
le véritable campagne de monsieur
sarkozy c'est lui notamment qui nous a
dit au tribunal
mais lui il m'a demandé pour la
philharmonie que nous faisons ensemble
l'état et la ville de faire exactement
la même chose donc je pense que de temps
en temps
l'intérêt général l'honnêteté